[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et aux côtés de nos alliés et
partenaires européens nous avons tout
fait pour l'éviter oui côté du nla
et nous sommes prêts non non non
oh là là là on n'est pas préparé
toi
cher poutine je voulais te dire que manu
a déconné excuses le et les jeunes quant
à moi j'adore la russie grâce à vous on
a eu la coupe du monde et j'ai une
poupée russe à la maison les bisous
salle de la jeunesse et l'assistance
sociale des cassos toujours présent
toujours que vous souhaitez un voix
beaux jours des voix bisous j'espère que
tout va bien pour vous je vous embrasse
fort bientôt la nouvelle saison arrive
et moi je vais faire du sport et à quoi
[Musique]
il m'a dit
ok
on va vraiment laissé un mec qui fait
des mouvements aussi dégueulasse
commencé nouvelle guerre mondiale ah non
là il faut réagir là à mon avis même si
coach ont peur de le corriger au risque
de finir au goulag vas-y vladimir
continue superbe mouvement super
exécution bon par contre si je poste
plus de vidéos après celle ci vous
comprendrez pourquoi laïque et à benoît
et redonne un arabe
bonjour à tous désolés pour cette coupe
de cheveux je suis toujours en tournage
juste une petite vidéo pour vous dire
que voilà malheureusement je quitte tik
tok parce que parce que j'ai
l'impression que la censure
ayez un peu gratuites et que et que les
gens de tik tok font un peu ce qu'ils
veulent avec les vidéos et ce que je
trouve dommage dans une époque où on se
bat pour la liberté d expression et où
on essaie de faire des vannes un peu sur
tous les sujets voilà moi j'essaie de
faire de l'humour sur le handicap
surtout ça et me faire censurer par par
une application c'est pas trop sait pas
trop ce dont j'ai envie aujourd'hui donc
voilà je vais partir c'est ma dernière
vidéo en tout cas merci à tous ceux qui
ont suivi merci à vous on a rapporté
4300 euros à handicap international
parce que c'était quand même le but de
ce conte tictoc à la base donc voilà
c'est en plus pour sa censure et à la
con fait des choses pour le handicap
j'imagine des gens qui ne connaissent
pas le handicap c'est un peu un peu
drôle